welcome back everyone
welcome to carcass 2k16
uh welcome to car cast 2k16 guys this is
uh we are attempting a full-blown
podcast from
my car and my camera is going to shut
off so we're like after 12 or 20 minutes
we don't know i think we got 20 minutes
what we'll do is uh well okay so it's 23
18
let's just
18
when it's uh 23 38
we will uh
i'm gonna let you know that we're gonna
have a cut and then uh we'll break for
sponsors i'll you know still transition
to sponsors then but uh this episode of
the jen and julian podcast slash car
cast is brought to you by pole and
branch get your
wonderful sheets bedding towels duvet
covers um all the the most amazing soft
things in your house get it with bowling
branch
they have an unbelievable selection we
are currently sleeping on bowling branch
sheets and we sleep like babies every
single night the kind of babies that
don't cry yeah soft babies that sleep
well
you can get 20 off your order right now
guys when you go to bull and branch dot
com and use product code jenna julian
that's also brought to you by me undies
get yourself a pair of the hottest
underwear in the game right now guys
soft undies
soft onions on soft sheets they have uh
something called micro modal fabric
fabric excuse me it's twice as soft as
cotton i'm currently wearing a pair can
they see if i do this
like wow but i can see can they say
those are my me on these guys that where
i'm all the time uh if you go to
meundies.com jenna julian you can get 20
off
your order of bandies oh my god we're
doing it we doing this okay but the rule
is that julian wants to keep this light
on and i said only but it really doesn't
distract him well i'm i'm fine i'm
driving with the lightning car a little
crazy to have the light on okay i mean
it also does look sus as [ __ ] like if
someone
if someone's looking at our car right
now this is the most sus thing ever so
we had this idea because we were gonna
podcast tonight it's friday night where
we are
we usually podcast on friday nights and
we've had a string of guests so we've
been doing it other nights yeah and
um
do you want any of this five author
authors sure i'll have some here
and so we were staying in the living
room first of all we went out looking
for a yellow lab that had gotten out of
its little
like yard and we have we're on like a
group uh community like cord in our
neighborhood and julian saw immediately
like oh no there's a dog that got out
and i'm like get my shoes get the
flashlight like let's go find it so we
did that for a little bit and then we
were like oh what should we podcast
about tonight and um we both just
decided that we really [ __ ] want
cupcakes and julian was like why don't
we do the podcast
from the car while we go try and get
cupcakes and the funny thing is guys
there's a good i would say 83 chance
that's being a little generous uh
probably like an 87 chance that we get
to this cupcake it's the cupcake atm so
it's open after hours sprinkles uh they
don't then they won't have vegan or
gluten free because i would say like a
lot of the time every time we go they do
not have it and we go anyway because
it's kind of like an adventurous we
could usually have doggy cupcakes though
so we could get them yeah so uh the goal
is
to get ourselves some cupcakes while
podcasting in the car um it's funny we
this week
jenna and i experienced or used a
lavalier mic for the first time a proper
lavalier might yeah
like a real one yeah we borrowed my
buddy keaton's from uh techsmart who was
on the podcast uh and we used it for
jenna's video this week she did asmr and
it was like we needed it for the video
and if any of you watch that video like
it turned out great audio-wise and this
is just yet another example of why we
need lav mics so this has pushed us over
the edge we are going to order two lav
mics and maybe even
you know bring it into the podcast room
and see how we like it you know i mean
it couldn't hurt to have some love
nights but i instead of
ideally just putting them on our shirt
like normal [ __ ] people who make
videos we have the money we have the
literal podcast mics
taped and mounted to these little
handles
as [ __ ] this is the most sus thing
especially if someone's listening to
this and you're not watching what we
look like you're listening to the audio
of us in a car and the car noises in
your car oh this girl is hammered right
now
oh my god like taxi cab confessions this
does feel like taxi cow's compassion are
you looking at her right now she's like
stumbling across the street
it's not polite i'm not staring i'm like
looking without looking you know
i think this is really cool because you
know people vlog from the car all the
time and uh
you know you see footage of people
talking in cars but like there aren't
too many people that do like a mobile
podcast
mobile podcast like this could be a
series guys we could do this this is
usually in a stationary store but i love
this is really exciting it's really cool
and if like if you guys like this and it
turns out not like the shittiest thing
in the entire world it could be the
worst thing ever we could do it it's
it's like i would say it's
probably gonna be really shitty it could
be really it's probably gonna be like if
you hate it really shitty if you hate it
let us know but also if you like it
that's really cool and exciting yes i
mean it's we're certainly not doing this
because we think it it could be
like the best thing ever we're just
we're just trying to try it because why
not just trying it to try it guys you
know what and like
this was a joke jenna was like
let's go get cupcakes because i was like
i want cupcake cupcakes and she was like
how about we podcast later i was like
how would we podcast on the way there
and i didn't even really think about it
i was just like kind of said it and you
know why not [ __ ] drive like how many
times are you listening to a podcast and
they're like oh look at that drunk lady
walking i love this that's what i love
like we're out on the street it is like
taxicab this is like we're creating a
genre right here like this is
we're out here in the world
this might exist we have just bear in
mind we haven't like looked it up
anytime jenna like wants a video idea or
i we want to make something we always
look to make sure
it doesn't exist and if it does exist we
credit wherever anyway so we don't know
if this exists or not we're not claiming
to be the first ones but this is sort of
a genre that i you know feel like i
haven't seen before it's like a podcast
like long-form podcast but in an
environment where the discussion itself
is not the center of attention like
you're actually out in the world like
this is you know this is similar to um
barbell shrugged is a podcast i listened
to like way a long ago a long time ago i
used to ambi coming up yeah he's coming
this is so [ __ ] lit right now isn't
this cool
check this out look at look he's looking
at us we're sucks as [ __ ] right now oh
there's a cop right there oh my god
we're doing anything illegal though i
think we are i'm not i don't think i'm
distracted i mean i'm hands-free anyway
uh they used to go to like events and
podcasts at like weightlifting meets so
that's kind of similar right yeah or
like a live podcast like people's live
products grace does one at vidcon there
you go you know oh i didn't know that's
really cool
or she has in the past oh i would love
to do that but it's still like the
person is stationary exactly so we're
moving like unless you're podcasting
from an airplane which is still like
you're in it and closed you don't get to
see what's going on
from a train what if we asmr podcasted
from an airplane like with lav mics on
we could totally do that where we just
whisper and we just we have the recorder
oh that's so obnoxious but it's like oh
you wouldn't even be able to hear us
because it's so loud on an airplane
anyway guys uh we were out looking for a
dog tonight
because uh on the board someone posted
they lost their dog and they ended up
going back
into their house this dog just like went
outside and then came back and
apparently that's like a normal thing
which is crazy to me if my dog is like i
had a freak out the other day because
the dogs escaped out of the front door
when jenna was getting the postmates so
mad at me i got too mad but it was it
was coming from a place of like genuine
freakoutness like i saw them run out the
door i was on the top deck literally
flying my drone i couldn't do anything
at the moment and i just see them both
towards the sidewalk because there was a
dog and
i you know i apologize for getting about
i shouldn't have gotten so mad but it
was uh you know for someone who's just
like oh yeah [ __ ] gridley's just
hanging out by the stop sign again like
dog's name is grizzly yeah like that's
that's terrifying like i would never
allow that that the she sort of just
lets the dog meander into the front yard
all the time
that's weird though can we just like
kind of too densely populated around us
to be like totally cool yeah like if we
lived somewhere in [ __ ] the midwest
where we had a whole farm and it was
like you could just let them walk but we
live in
there's cars this this guy's next to us
like what the [ __ ] is going on
i mean if anything gets lit you know
like we could [ __ ] roll down a window
and just
i don't know we could we could
absolutely ruin that
we have no idea what's gonna happen we
are podcasting for my car right now
yeah but to be fair like about when uh
when pg ran out yeah i don't know if any
of you guys have dogs and you have dogs
that like lunge at the door when you
open it peach is pretty good but you
were upstairs flying your drone and i
opened the door and the postmate was
really sweet he kind of we ordered
coffees and he handed me the coffees and
then he's like hey i know who you are
you're jenna so we started talking for a
second and all three dogs ran out
because there was a dog walking it was
just like the worst timing for the dog
to be walking across and then i had
coffees in my hand and this guy was
talking to me like it didn't even really
faze him he was like oh geez can i help
you and i'm like yes please
yeah and sorry
yeah and you know
i love like there's been post mates that
have said hi that they recognize me and
they watch my vlogs and it means so much
it's awesome it's just that specific
moment could have like it was just the
worst timing and he could never have
known really like
he might think it's regular for them to
run
behind him but even if they ran out like
he might think it's totally regular
because you were keeping your composure
you know you weren't like freaking out
yeah if you start freaking out yeah they
get like super stressed i just had to go
grab marbles because marvel ran right up
to the dog and was like
yeah and and of course marvel wasn't
doing anything he just gets in their
face and barks and i really apologize to
the woman and especially the dog i was
like i'm so sorry for making you walk
stressful a little baby
yeah i'd be pissed if i was just out for
a little walk yeah some little dog came
up to me and was barking at me i mean
i'd laugh it off because it's marble is
so laughably small but
you know anyway um
you know we were out looking for a good
45 minutes just for that dog and uh we
we met the people who actually were
posting on the same post that we found
and they knocked on the door and heard
gridley bark and we're like oh it's all
good so
i just wouldn't call it sleep like when
you know a dog like someone is looking
for their dog and they can't find them
that makes me so like i can't not do
anything
yeah i mean it's it's unfortunate but
it's just a style of you know i don't
want to say like
certain dog parents are shitty dog
parents it's just a style like people
have different styles they have they're
a lot more lacks with their dogs and i
don't want to sit here and and judge
them but at the same time i do not
relate to that at all like um when we
were in joshua tree we found those two
dogs and they were just walking down the
street
it's impossible that people didn't see
it like them like they many many people
because it was a populated street would
have had to see them before we saw them
well it was still daylight there was
daylight and they were just watching
and and you have to think like
those people who saw the dog inevitably
were like you know oh they're fine that
posted it on the board yeah instead of
like walking outside and going to get
the dog they posted it on the board and
i was like if you saw a dog walking
around i wouldn't think to myself oh i'm
going to go post this on the board i'd
go outside and get the dog well they
might
have sense of altruism but you know it's
that too and and i the thing
the fact that someone posted on the
board i can appreciate that so much like
i joined this thing and
it's it's such a cool thing uh that i
think the app is called next door which
is it's basically like a an area
facebook page but it's designed
specifically for neighborhoods so you
know if someone's knocking on doors and
they're being suspicious they'll [ __ ]
post about it and then immediately
everyone will know and they push
notifications to your phone it's really
cool and the fact that someone posted
about it and it wasn't their dog even if
they were out they were not out looking
actively like at least they care enough
to like write a sentence on the app and
jenna and i you know i was like oh just
got a notification let's go look for
this dog yeah let's [ __ ] him there
um
but yeah it just felt really good
knowing that he was safe and sound
because uh no matter whose dog it is
it's a dog you know you don't want them
out wandering alone and scared
but i
i have seen many many dogs there's some
of them that i can't catch i've actually
like been trying to catch dogs in the
past that you see in l.a more than
anywhere else in my life
um i feel like because the weather is
warm and people often have their dogs
outside like back east most people have
their dogs on leashes or fenced in but
in the winter you know you don't often
see a bunch of dogs running around
outside and they're not out because
they're all inside nor does your dog
want to [ __ ] run away
it's cold out there
um
but i've seen a lot of dogs or chased
after a lot of dogs in los angeles and
you don't see anybody around or like
trying and you know i it just baffles me
sometimes how people don't have
the i think you know the [ __ ]
bystander effect they're like oh i'm
sure someone's out looking for that dog
or i'm sure somebody's trying to catch
him or i'm sure everything's fine i'm
sure somebody's doing something and i'm
like no be that person and put your
shoes on and go get that you like miss
lippy you go get get out and find that
find that
like
this is also another thing that's very
very much easier said than done you know
it's very easy to sit here and say
don't be the bystander go act and do it
because in the moment it is
nerve-wracking like you know i have to
go look for these socks or if you see
the dogs you're going to go chase these
dogs there's like a lot goes to your
head okay but maybe this is something
that i'm really comfortable feeling like
i can help with like chasing a dog is
something that i'm like i'm ready to go
do something but if i saw you know
someone had really hurt themselves i'm a
person that's going to be a victim of
the bystander effect you know yes i'm
not necessarily going to run up to
someone and be like oh let me fashion
you a tourniquet real quick so we can
stop your blood loss
you know yeah i think it's it's depends
on the situation and the person too yeah
like you're a lot more comfortable with
dogs but maybe someone who hasn't like
they're no they don't really they're not
a dog person if they're in their like
late 60s they're probably not going to
go run sprint after a dog yeah
yeah but i will yeah
i think it's different for different
scenarios it is catching dogs it really
hurts my heart sometimes when i see a
dog and you know no frantic person in a
car for you know you don't see them in a
couple minutes yeah or around or anybody
else
wow i'm here right now we are in north
hollywood now we are pulling up
lankershim in uh
magnolia
this is uh this place is popping there's
a bar up the street that we like to go
to and then there's also things called
house of pies or house of some pie place
and it's like the coolest coffee shop
where you can get freshly made personal
pies they actually have gluten-free pies
too um
we actually went here
when we dropped the dogs off at the vet
you know to wait it out it's a cookie
yeah there's the brickyard that's the
bar we like and then where's yeah
what is it called house of
republic
republic of pi it's a great spot i'm
really curious to to try their pie
sometime
um but i like north hollywood i like
follow two because it's got life to it
it's a lot of younger people and a lot
of dancers a lot of dancers a lot of
young people and and you know not like
in the entertainment
no no they're like like detroit
stanchers
there's a lot of people in
entertainment industry in north
hollywood not like the really douchey
type like there's a lot of self doers
out here i've met a lot of youtubers who
live in north hollywood it's pretty cool
it's a cool spot it's cool spot i like
it
um
we we uh
well we're about halfway through the
year
it's crazy right
we are it's number six of the months
also
um let's take a moment rest in peace
muhammad ali man
yeah we just saw it he uh yeah it's
friday night right now
he passed away it's very unfortunate but
man that guy was uh he was incredible he
was a legend he's like a he was a
renegade you know
so it's very sad
it was crazy how that happened it was
like complications then he was put on
live sport and then he passed away all
in like the span of a day i think right
yeah
it was very fast yeah
um yeah anyway so it's june so we're
halfway through it's crazy to think that
a whole half a year has passed since
what since well just 2016 i feel like we
were just doing our new year's
resolution podcast wait did we do a new
year's resolution podcast this year
we did it 2015. sorry i but there's
always you know there's a celebration
it's like it's new year's
in my mind at least it's always like a
benchmark like
2016 started here like i always think of
like when we take a trip to see your
brother for christmas that is the final
thing we do that year you know because
it's always in december during the
holidays so
i don't know
it's kind of flown by i guess but i feel
like i'm always saying things are flying
by okay red light oh m actual g
imagine if we ran the red light in the
picture of us it's just podcasting in
the car
those are so funny the pictures of
people running red lights yeah oh my god
the best one that i saw was waleed
muhammad's vine that he made of the one
that he did do you remember that yes i
did
he's running a red light at night with
his sunglasses on just like making a
peace sign or like flipping oh didn't he
whip i thought he would something stupid
and it looks so [ __ ] walid he was
like i ran this red light and just got
this in the mail and it was worth it
yeah
it's a [ __ ] show absolute punk shot abso
all right so this guy's crossing the
street and he went up to some car
and went to the window it looked like he
was
his friend taking money or
is he homeless no oh this guy's they got
to turn around what the hell's that see
yeah what
classic them they're just looking at us
and then they get a turnout they're like
smug they're like we get to turn
i don't think anyone just did that yeah
that was made up
uh anyway it's
it's been 20 minutes
uh so
i would say
i should pull over and do the sponsors
yeah what do you think about that
okay so
don't mind this quick cut because we
need to restart the camera so
are you warm
what because i am i'm wearing some me
undies right now they keep you so warm
and cool at the same time
grab yourself a pair of me and these
guys there's new designs i think every
single month they have these awesome
designers they have so many designs
already on their website what keith
herring keith herron yeah and the ones
i'm wearing are [ __ ] cool and uh they
are legit the softest underwear you will
put on your little bottom
whether you're wearing suits or sweats a
suit or sweat you spend almost 24 hours
a day
in your underwear guys that is a lot of
hours each day if you think about it you
really are in your underwear like all
the time yeah right except for unless
you shower in your underwear
well this sponsor is not for nudists
i don't appreciate that
i was just saying that those might be
the only people that don't spend 24
hours a day in there everywhere yeah
um guys instead of making a statement
like superman's
tights
under underwear
or that's boring just wear some me
undies that's the statement you want to
make
so get yourself a pair of minions go to
meundies.com jenna julian and get
yourself 20 percent off your first order
that's meundies.com i also want you guys
to tweet us pictures of your me undies
when you get it tweet us as a podcast
whatever but it doesn't have to be on
your butt no
i'm not asking for butt pics
i'm asking for underwear picks you know
put it on your dog or something make
them look goofy uh that's me and these
guys thank you to me andy's they are a
great sponsor please go support them it
makes the podcast free for you to watch
uh bowling branch guys our other sponsor
this week they've reimagined sheets by
cutting out the middlemen they cut out
markups you don't have to go to the
store who goes to the store to buy
sheets anymore what are you what are you
old what are you outdated
uh and they deliver right to your door
uh not only not only do you treat you
guys your custody their customers fairly
they treat their workers fairly which is
so nice to know when you're buying
something they're the first betting
company that's ever received fair trade
certification so you never have to worry
about how or where the sheets were made
so
get yourself some sheets know that they
were made
with respect to the workers and everyone
else involved
and if you don't like them you guys can
try your sheets for 30 nights risk-free
and if you don't absolutely love them
you can send them back
no questions asked you will get your
money back
not that you will want to send them back
because they are the dopest uh and it
gets even better guys go to
bowlingbranch.com today for 20 of your
whole order sheets towels blankets duvet
covers everything plus free shipping in
their beautifully packaged signature
boxes that's boltanbranch.com use code
jenna julian for the discount thank you
to our sponsors
and let's go all right let's go let's
get it uh we realized
that the camera we are using right now
will
when it records more than four gigs
it'll cut a clip so there might have
been a cut
earlier on in the podcast which we
didn't plan for and there might be a cut
coming up which we won't plan for uh
we'll try to do a quick cross dissolve
so you guys don't really notice that i
pay attention to it just wanted to shout
that out let you guys know we're not
losing our minds and the podcast is not
we oh
404 a podcast not
found
clybourne ave this area is cool i walked
around here one time
one time you walked around here yeah i
walked around here one time i was with
josh we uh we
walked from where did we go we walked
from the sex club which is the sushi
place we like to go to we call the sex
club
and
that's like a mile from here we were
just walking and talking it was one of
those things where you're walking and
you're in such a good conversation you
don't even realize how far you've walked
we walked like four miles in total that
night and we were just in the
conversation it was so full it was
really cool he took me to this it was
nice you guys are like sweet little
bromance
brothers yeah and he took me to this bar
i think we're gonna pass it it's pretty
great okay um
why
okay let me explain i want to tell you
the story so
i i hope it's a on the right maybe it's
not or on the left i don't know anyway
it's this old bar
and when i say it's an old bar i don't
mean that the bar itself was built a
long time ago i mean that everyone in
there is older than my mom
so this was maybe a
tuesday wednesday some middle of the
week day
um
like 10 p.m we're just walking and he's
like
you want to grab a drink real quick and
i'm like yeah sure so he was like let's
let's pop in here it's it's mostly an
older crowd but let's let's just do it
i'm like oh yeah i don't mind that at
all so we walk in and literally like
like everyone is like in their 50s and
60s it's like the cr i've never seen
anything like and they're all turning up
like they are it's loud there's loud
[ __ ] country music i don't even know
if there's a live band country music oh
yeah it's like a western bar i can't get
down oh my god so
dancing or whatever there was dancing
i don't think there was a style
um
and it
said we got we go in we go to this old
old school bar with old people and we
like order a drink and i'm just getting
eyes from all these like
that's their spot you're on their turf
yeah like from oh my god it was the
craziest thing so we we look at each
other and even he didn't really expect
what we walked into like
he knew it was what it was but he didn't
expect like it was popping it was middle
of the week
is this it
what i think this might be it
what's it called
no that's not it that looks like a cool
spot though
it does that looks like another country
bar it looks like a western movie yeah
it does flap there's literally like a
flap or like in an old saloon or
whatever you call it right um
so we order our drinks we kill them as
fast as we we could and then we left
um
as we're leaving across the street from
the bar there's a there's an old home
and we're like do you think they all
just like walked over here yes and got
hammered everyone's back this is their
free night
oh my god it was very cool it was like
cool to see that many old people getting
like crunk i had never seen anything
like it except at like weddings
yeah but if you've ever been to parts of
florida there's plenty of places like
that like near retirement communities i
haven't spent that much time in florida
so people get [ __ ] turned people get
turnt turn
two turn five me three turns
it would be way funnier if there was
just like non-stop like frank sinatra or
something yeah
yeah the country music country music
yeah
and i forget the name i wish i remember
the name i'll text you off he definitely
knows the name by heart like he's he's
been there a number of times he went
back after that
that wasn't his first no no like the
what the time he took me was not his
first time like he had been there a
couple times oh you guys just went there
we just went there yeah
um he said he had danced with an older
woman one time when he was there hanging
out sweet it is sweet
we should have josh on the podcast we
will have josh on the podcast uh we
we're talking about it this week but
then we got caught up with like a
million other things
but he's down so we'll have him on the
podcast and then perhaps a separate
episode with colleen so we can each give
them
an entire episode i feel like that would
work we could also have them on the same
episode but i i want to focus on each of
them
for their own episodes so they can have
so we'll we'll try to do that we also
have a couple other guests
coming up guys that we're working on
i'm excited i'm excited too the podcast
is my favorite fam
um yeah so currently i don't really know
if we're in the right direction for
where are we right now
i know i got i got caught up in the
podcast i'm just driving okay
making me nervous
babe do you want me to help you babe all
it is is the car cast
it's making sure i look like you act
like you've been here before it's a car
cast baby who's ever in this situation
all it is is the car cast
like it's literally
literally the most stressful complex
trip we've ever taken in our car no
that's not true we've taken a lot more
stressful trips in our car i'd say
anytime that we're driving up to my
brother's like at christmas time when
you take
like your camera or the gopro or
something and you clip it with that
stupid clip on the door and then we're
just driving with this camera like on
the side of the car like not even a
gopro like mounted from the inside or
like on the hood or something it's like
hanging out on the side yeah that
terrifies me
all it is is a car cast
no that's not a car cast i don't know
why i said that i do it because it's
worth it when you put the gopro on the
side of the car like
this last trip to oregon was cool and
like i shot some cool stuff but a year
ago that when we were 2014 or 2015. i
think it was year 2014 we were driving
and i put the gopro out and it was like
recording a time lapse of a span of
maybe like 45 minutes to an hour and in
that 45 minutes we hit
sunny like we were on the five we hit
like the sunny skies of like la then we
went into this like crazy fog and then
we went into this like heavy rainstorm
and then we got back into a sunny and
you saw the transformation of like all
that weather from like the car that was
the coolest thing that's why i make you
nervous by doing that
but instead you got a beautiful shot
that will live forever on the internet
but it's a clip have you ever felt how
strong that clip is it's not going to
just fall off although it does
if you're driving in a car that it's
clipped to the outside of it's scary
it's like you do admit that it's scary
that's scary but it's worth it i would
do it again i do do it again i'm doing
it right now look at your window
just kidding i think the funniest uh
bizarre thing so far that you've done
is periscope from your drone
that's pretty dirty it's so [ __ ] i
don't know if you if any of you guys saw
it or have seen anyone do it like no
one's doing it because it's ridiculous
it's cool but it's there's some flaws in
terms of being able to connect to
periscope
um because oftentimes when you're flying
the drone you lose signal in terms of it
being able to stream because we're we're
in a densely populated area if you were
in the middle of
you know not a city i'm sure it would be
better but
so you're seeing on periscope the aerial
footage of the city and you're getting
the audio it's like the audio of just
julian up close to his phone so you see
this like a big sweeping view of like
the city with someone being like
asmr drone
that's what it is really though it looks
ridiculous
and it keeps cutting out so like you'll
see four seconds of it it's like oh [ __ ]
sorry i don't know what's going on hold
on and then it's just like no sound in
just the city and then like like if you
didn't know who that like you you're
like what the [ __ ] what am i watching
what is this it's like um
it's it's stressful enough to fly it's
around period
but put putting it on periscope is so
much more stressful
for so many reasons
namely if you do anything [ __ ] up or a
mate accident or something you crash
it's broadcast immediately to everyone
so your [ __ ] up is everyone's enjoyment
but not only that yeah like boozy he
fell off his bike or whatever yeah i
don't know something happened apparently
that was legit
i'll use periscope yeah um but not only
that
when you fly the drone
my drone is dji and there's an app for
it so you plug your your like an iphone
or an ipad into the controller
and you go to the app and you get to see
the distance the speed the live view the
radar the signal connection like
everything you might need to know it's
your hud it's like you it's a cockpit
basically
pit
but when you go when you periscope from
the drone you have to be in the
periscope app on that phone so you don't
get any of that information all you're
getting is a shittier signal of the live
feed and so it's very hard to steer
adjust everything uh that's that's
probably what makes it really hard but
you know sometimes you got a live stream
from your drone hey smart i feel you
i think that we should stop this
recording so it doesn't cut okay and
then come back and describe whether or
not we were able to get sprinkles
cupcakes because i don't want to end i
don't know where we are right now julian
i don't want to leave the car like this
we're gonna
if someone sees a car like this this is
like a gold mine you want to break it
down before we go i don't know what do
you think i mean
i'm gonna leave the podcast hanging
about whether or not we got
cupcakes okay we can always write it in
the description if you don't
we're still eight minutes away
but you want to cut the stop sign yeah i
know that's it
you want to cut and then we'll come back
after sprinkles
yeah all right all right guys we are
gonna cut
and we will be back after sprinkles to
let you know if we got cupcakes yeah
but thank you so far for hanging out
with us while we're cut actually it's
gonna be instant for you but when you
have a second check out our sponsors
all right we'll be right back
so
we are back
from the cup our cast 2k6 kkktm
unfortunately
as we expected they had no vegan
cupcakes
but they did have a gluten-free cupcake
they had a gluten-free cup which never
happens i feel like that's the first
time we've ever been to the sprinkles
where they have a gluten free cup they
have a gluten-free cupcake yeah but they
also had no doggy cupcakes which was
pretty much out of everything good yeah
so i feel like we're gonna get home and
the dogs are gonna be like someone got a
cupcake it didn't get me into exactly
not that they love those doggy cupcakes
anyway they're just kind of mad about it
but it's the gesture i think
well yeah like if you if if ever we
leave the house and come back and give
them something i feel like they're
offended yeah they are
they act like it too they like sniff
your [ __ ] and they're like what what's
this you wouldn't got this excuse you
you enter the world and bring me a gift
you didn't come bearing gifts from the
world
uh as you're leaving the parking
structure this woman was pulling some
crazy [ __ ] and it got us thinking that
right that we wanted to talk kind of
about
shitty things that people do when they
drive since this is the car cast
yeah i [ __ ] i hate a lot of people
that drive yeah i hate almost everyone
because i feel like people don't drive
cautiously in los angeles and it makes
me crazy
yeah um well this why don't you say what
she was doing
i don't know it was like it was pretty
hard to describe we were trying to get
out of the parking garage they were just
stopped and there were like 12 people
doing a chinese fire drill
but let's paint the picture here they
were all dressed up really nice it was a
benz and there was someone taking there
was like 10 people and like one car
surrounding one car and they all were
like gonna take this picture
but they didn't pull over they were
literally stopped into the road so i
pulled up behind her waiting for uh you
know a normal [ __ ] human being to
keep driving and she looks at me and
just goes go around
and i'm like oh like
first of all like that's that should
have been common knowledge y'all are
just gonna take your nice little fan
picture inside of parking structure
without pulling over at all like not
even not even turn just completely
center the road she acted like i was
like an idiot for not knowing that i
should have just gone around her
come on
i don't like people that honk i don't
like people that drive fast
i don't like any of that i don't like
anyone
that
so
say there's
a right turn lane
and a go straight lane
but you're behind someone and they're
going straight but you want to turn
right and it's a red light but you can
go right on red which jenna's never
gonna agree with me on that but um
like say the person in front of you is
not pulled all the way up to the front
of the line they're kind of hanging back
for whatever reason which means the
wedging between that car and maybe a
parked car right here is impossible
because they're they're closing it off
but they have maybe 15 yards ahead of
them they just don't want to pull up and
they know you're gonna turn but for some
reason they they pull short of the light
which bothers me to no end because it
takes little to well literally zero
effort because you're supposed to pull
up to the light anyway why are you
pulling up short when it's
inconveniencing me i almost feel like
they're doing it passive aggressively
too i don't maybe not maybe they're not
paying attention i hate people that
insist on training right on red when
it's not safe i have people do that
you get mad at me they rush around you
when it's a one lane
um cool gets mad at me because sometimes
i won't turn right on red because it
doesn't feel safe and like i don't want
to whip in the traffic really quick
julie be like turn you could you'd write
on red like let's go i'm like i don't
want to it's a choice you don't have to
turn right on red and people get mad at
me and people honk at me but i feel like
it's dangerous sometimes and i don't
feel like it well fair enough but
sometimes when you think it's dangerous
it's not dangerous it's just a main road
i don't know i do know that because i
have eyes and i see that there's
literally no cars no cars
i have eyes i know what what i'm looking
at i don't know
what do you what do you mean you don't
know we know from looking
our
i drive very cautiously and very safely
and so it frustrates me sometimes when i
feel like not everyone has that same
sense of urgency about driving safely
i understand that it's not me i don't
trust it's other people i don't know i
get that you have to drive defensively
but there is a time and a place for
turning right on red and it's not that
time and place is sometimes
you you think it's all the time yes i do
it's not it's not all the time i am so
lost right now
i have no idea where i am
because my phone's dead and i can't get
directions i think i gotta turn right
out of the action
oh yeah yeah do you want me to yeah do
you mind
what's like so we just drove all this
way to get cupcakes that we didn't know
we're going to be there yeah like
weren't really there yeah well it's like
the craziest thing you've ever done to
get food that you wanted sorry really
quickly that's another thing that i hate
people do whenever they turn left when
they turn left and like completely cut
off your lane like if you weren't there
i mean if you were there they would have
crashed into you oh my god
um
what is the craziest thing i've done for
well
or like most work you've done to get
food i'm trying to think like let's get
started oh my god
she needs to pipe
like pipe all the way down
i
i don't i i
can tell you what i've done yeah like
give me one ears maybe it'll maybe so
when i was in college i made the mistake
of telling everyone how delicious
garbage plates were
and i would end up
like they opened at like 10 a.m like
every place called hawks penfield hots
henrietta hots all those places would
make garbage plates and nick tahoe's was
the original for those who don't know
what a garbage plate is we talked about
it in a couple podcasts but it's like
home fries mac salad and then like
cheeseburgers on top with like hot sauce
and ketchup and mustard and it looks
awful but it's very delicious back when
i was still eating meat and stuff and um
i would always rave about it and talk
about how i missed it tell my friends
and they're like hey next time you go
home bring one for me so it started off
as like me bringing a garbage plate to
my friend or like my roommate or
something
and like i would drive from rochester to
boston so i would wake up at like
9 30 9 15 9 o'clock or whatever pack up
my car
call in an order to henrietta hats which
was my favorite
and get you know a couple of garbage
plates that drive six plus hours with it
in my car with marbles and he would just
smell hot meat
the entire way four more
go crazy because he wanted to eat it
poor marbles was right and then i would
give it to my friend they'd be like oh
my god this is amazing this is like the
best thing ever i'm like i know right
well then it just got worse because
everyone kept telling everyone how good
they were and to ask me to bring them
some so i think the worst was like
i maybe brought 10 orders like 10
garbage plates in one trip that's right
from rochester to boston and they all
come in these like styrofoam boxes
like you know the like dinner size yeah
styrofoam box
the entire back seat of my car is full
of garbage plates and just smells like
garbage plates and then i had to give
them to people like some of them i
weren't going to see for like the next
day and they all come with bread and
like all this other stuff yeah so it's
like i i'm driving all of these [ __ ]
garbage plates to people
i mean that's a lot of work that's like
doing free delivery that's what that is
you're working for free state lines
is that illegal like transporting
garbage plates i think that's illegal
it is not illegal but like did you ever
watch making the band the show no
you were too young i did not yeah it was
it was probably on
vh1 or mtv or whatever yeah
um
when you were
too young to watch it but it was an
amazing show and pd decided that he was
going to put his contestants through
absolute hell and he made them walk
across like forever and across the
brooklyn bridge to get him cheesecake
and back
cheesecake savage
like you've never done like got
completely gone out of your way for food
or something you wanted to eat we uh we
did that in new york
yeah well ireland too restaurant
yeah and ireland and ireland basically
everywhere you've gone with me we've had
to go out of the other way find me food
yeah um
but uh recently when we were in orlando
for playlist
we were getting home on a sunday night
but we were getting in at like 9 10 p.m
like pretty late and all i had thought
about this entire weekend
was pizza from fresh bread it's my
favorite pizza spot the vegan pizza that
we get it's amazing that's all i was
thinking about the whole weekend and we
were like when we get back home from
playlist on sunday we will get us a nice
big old pizza and go you know go in on
it because we deserve it it's been a
long
weekend of playlisting and flights and
everything
then like halfway through the weekend we
realize
uh
we're not we're going to get into late
like after they close they close at like
8 30 and we're gonna land
so
julian who needs pizza brain was like
all right
let's text colin who's our next door
neighbor
he's like 17 by the way yeah he's
awesome
uh and i was like
yo you want free pizza
and he was like he was like why what's
up
um
uh and he was like one time i was like
can you please maybe receive a pizza for
us i'll get i'll buy you a pizza if you
do it like snake stand out front of our
house pretend like you're me
and sign for the pizza when it gets
there so we can have pizza like while
they're open and he did it and he was
like totally down and he did
so cool
um
he like we we owe him a big one for that
so we got home
and he actually brought the pizza to his
house to keep it warm in his house like
what a guy
but it was just so funny
that we like i i was like i need this
[ __ ] pizza
so i'm gonna get it
really nice
but i think that's one of the most
recent ways i've like really gone on my
way to food you need that pizza i needed
the pizza if i could have eaten like
really ask someone to do you a favor
yeah like there were obviously so many
different options for cheating or having
like a really naughty meal or whatever
but i needed that pizza and so i had to
have it so i got it
with the help of our neighbor we were
starving
we were starving so hungry we like
didn't eat much in orlando at all yeah i
mean
like a lot of the places in orlando
although i've heard that there are some
places in florida that are much more
progressive in terms of offering like
just not meat or things like that a lot
of the hotels and stuff like their their
dining menu or often their decor is sort
of just like stuck in the late 90s very
old you know so
you'll see something like beef
stroganoff on the
on the menu for your
rover dining or whatever you're just
like we literally ate
french fries rice and fruit the whole
time which i wasn't complaining about
but at the same time the amount of food
was a lot lower than our normal like
caloric
oh my god
what are you doing i'm trying to drive
on the freeway while we podcast that's
what i'm doing
i know we're taking the freeway back
this is scary as [ __ ] well i don't know
how to get back without the freeway i'm
like kind of lost that's okay
is our camera tilted
i don't know well you can see it i can't
it's sort of tilted i'll fix it there we
go
god this is ghetto if we do this again
if we use again it'll be a lot better
i'm gonna get off
not as
it was loud
sorry i just was lost i had no idea how
to get back without the freeway it's
okay you can only do what you can do on
the carcass 2k 16 car cast
so you guys know that obnoxious song
that i was playing the panda remix with
um
oh my god i'm just sorry i'm just
pulling up sorry this is this is not
legal i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm so oh my god oh my god
julian what i had to get to the left
lane
you pulled over here and you turned off
the leg yeah because in case of cop saws
i don't want the light to be on i'm just
going this way nothing's happening car
cast just got so [ __ ] it's fine
you're making a big deal it's not a big
deal i just had to pull a little to the
left
why did you get off the highway if if
you don't know where we're going
because i didn't want the noise in the
podcast i felt bad about the noise
oh my god
my god oh my god on the way back this is
so much our camera just everything's
breaking down i don't know how to
tighten it okay
let me pull over just hold it hold it
all right no hold the camera
hold the camera this is literally all
you have to do i'm holding it
why don't we take a break for a second
no no let's power through
we can do it oh my god we can do it we
can do it all right
all right let's just pull over here
it's this week i think this is the worst
podcast we've ever done
give us some credit
is that better yes
no well it's it's it's you have to
tighten it in a way that we can
i can't tighten it i don't know what to
tighten i put my hand on that thing and
there's like 12 knobs and i do not know
what to tighten all right i think that's
good
oh my god
[ __ ] it all anyways what i was saying
though is that annoying remix of panda
and uh
seinfeld where are you not going i don't
know
i don't know i'm just like lost i'm
trying to do a good job here that
person's bumper sticker says honk if you
love cheese
fair enough
why do we both why do we both have ways
open on our phone there's two phones
sitting here
with waze open
this podcast should really be called
like how you argue in the car with
someone while you're podcasting yeah
it's pretty it's pretty real
pretty [ __ ] real
give you that much oh my god no i was
saying that annoying remix yeah panda
and seinfeld i saw a vine i've seen it
before but i just found it again i was
dying somebody did the seinfeld the
music with uh numb by
it's the worst thing i've ever heard
i feel like that should be a genre of
music though just remixing awful like
whatever
music with
seinfeld themed music
to make the worst remix of all time like
like the worst the song
the better like it should be called like
your blood your blood yeah because it
makes your ears feel like they're going
to bleed
you see it then the vine zooms in on
jerry seinfeld's face of course it does
wait now i want to play it oh you think
i wrecked it
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i don't know what to do i don't your
phone freaked out at me i don't know
what to do
you know what it's like probably not
even my phone's fault probably it is
it's 100
probably not my phone's fault i'm being
honest here cats 2k16 the least lit
podcast there ever was what is that
beeping
i heard that too
i don't know are we hitting some
interference do we drive by like aliens
oh we are near like warner brothers
studios we could have hit like a signal
thing with
why would that affect anything though i
don't know
yeah i don't know i don't know anything
at all ever about anything actually
i don't even know what direction i'm
driving i don't have a compass
oh
see this this sensation that i have
while i listen to that makes
i'm not i'm not trying i'm getting
directions over this vine
this is the most uncomfortable feeling
in the world
why i feel like i feel like my chest is
in a knot
like i feel tense when i hear that i
just realized yeah it was 27 days ago
when i got put out i realized at the
bottom instead of it saying seinfeld it
says end my life
but they they like cut the word seinfeld
to spell it because the words end my
life you could spell from seinfeld
except for the y which they
maneuvered
it was ridiculous
oh my god
oh oh oh oh what it's a siren
i'm just saying oh my god you scared
this [ __ ] out hi cause i thought we were
getting pulled over right now
god this is like such a stressful
podcast
this is the most stressful podcast ever
i was convinced i was getting pulled
over so
[ __ ] everything we put him on the
podcast
we just keep rolling
registration uh are you gonna introduce
yourself to the dink fam and look who we
have coming on next officer what's your
name what's your name we'll put your
link in the description what's your
twitter i follow him
what do you think you could get in
trouble for if you were podcasting
i think he would probably say
the camera is you know in a place where
it's probably impeding your vision
therefore i i judge this as distracted
driving their former right you take it i
feel like the whole distracted driving
thing is pretty arbitrary so he could
probably just take it up i don't know
the law on that at all because i know
people have gotten in trouble for having
those like big furry dice and stuff like
people
cops will pull you over and say that
you're not allowed to have them because
they're blocking a portion of your
windshield yeah but like what exactly is
the law like who are they to say what's
distracting you
a cop
well like what's the law
i actually don't know technically the
distracted driving law i don't that's
why i would just assume he would take at
us because if i knew law i would at
least have the power of knowledge
knowing my law you know knowing my
rights in that
situation hills oh my god knowledge any
time i say that word
knowledge knowledge
next question three
what do you say three lamborghinis in my
lamborghini account
if you guys don't know who ty lopez is
oh he's legendary guy that made that
commercial do you know he trains
jiu-jitsu how mad does that make you no
he does he trains you too what does he
do with his glasses he he's like one of
those guys who only does like privates
you know with like he doesn't go to
class you know ashton kutcher is like a
brown belt or whatever
no yeah he's a beast brown yeah brown i
think he's a brown belt he was a purple
bell last time i checked
it like a real brown belt oh yeah
someone just no no no
no no he's i think he's trained with
jean-jacques machado for like years
years and years and years which
obviously you have to train for to get
up to get around no babe it's legit it's
a fact i don't know why you're you're
thinking it's up for grabs like it's
that is a thing he is a jujitsu i think
browned out possibly purple belt legit
he's a legit jiu jitsu practitioner i
don't know about all that why are you
saying you don't know about it it's a
fact you can't if you say two plus two
is four i wouldn't say ah you know i
don't really know i don't know how i
feel about that that's some [ __ ] we
did that in a video remember being
skeptical at the time it's so annoying
oh god mildly annoy other people what
time is it oh it's uh oh 37
like it's so infuriating oh my god
it's so annoying i feel like my mom has
done that to me in the past or she'll
ask me something that's because she
knows it gets to you and she'll be like
i don't think that's right
we should do a video where we like ask
people for directions and when they tell
us we're like i don't think you're right
it's so frustrating
like the time is really bad the time's
really bad because that is not debatable
at all
like someone looking at like their their
smartphone that tells them the time like
you don't have to set it and be like yes
yeah what street is this ah this is uh
koenga
no
it's like says kawanga right there i
don't think so that signs outdated
i don't think it is and then like as
they try to leave we'll just follow them
you're like wait no seriously can you
tell me where this is no you ask someone
in passing for directions and then you
just turn around and follow the person
they're like oh yeah you're gonna go
that way just keep on i'm surprised
andrew hales hasn't done this and then
you just walk right next to them like
you keep falling like you completely
ignored what they said
nice nice nice
oh i think we're finally uh on track to
get home are we back in noho somewhere
yeah we're near no home no
huh you debating
my facts
it's funny
like i'll confirm that later i think
he's a brown belt he might be purple
belt i don't know about that either way
he's um he's trained with machado i
think it's john jack machado for a long
time i don't think that's who he trains
with okay
you know i just don't think that's not
okay
okay
hopefully the camera doesn't fall my
phone died update everyone my phone just
died
we're low on fuel low on people
this is not a joke
everything might just crumble right now
[ __ ] at all
your iphone has just been disconnected
yep because it's dead so what am i gonna
what am i gonna do with this
you can't i can't eat it i can't eat it
no i'm not going to eat it while you sit
there and watch me
glaring at me with this podcast and we
were going to get cupcakes and we got no
cupcakes you know why don't i bring it
to colin
paying back for the pizza does he eat
gluten-free cupcake you're gonna go
knock on his door ah actually i think he
only eats gluten cupcakes i don't think
he can have this
he's allergic to non-gluten
once there's an absence of gluten in his
food he reacts
oh my god
like what if someone made up that as a
as their medical condition to just like
carb load i told you my friend in high
school
he
in high school that was probably the
worst time for me as a ceo because it
was before it got popular and things
were everywhere but it was i was in high
school so everything's [ __ ] awkward
and you feel bad and whatever he would
be like every time we would eat together
he'd be like you know i i'm i know you
have to eat gluten-free but i'm gonna
just get a couple extra sides of gluten
and just eat it and also
he would also tell me that he shot up
with gluten
free into his arm
what was it there's that beeping
some sort of feedback aliens
aliens does whatever a spider can
all right so how do we wrap this podcast
up i i feel like it needs to end with a
bang not literally i don't want to oh my
god why would you say no okay oh i
literally just said not literally
i just said not like we should end this
thing with a [ __ ] smash
jenna hates jenna hates when i do this
he pretends to turn the wheel oh we got
a turn julian
julian my dad used to do that that's why
i do it oh well that's why i was raised
that way
[ __ ] a man do not
don't um
if you guys genuinely think like
obviously next time we do this if we
ever do it again we'll have lav mics
we'll have the camera better figured out
but if you really liked it and we can do
it during the day too so we don't need
this [ __ ] light but if you really
want us to do this again we will
absolutely do this again because this is
cool i like mixing it up
i think it's fun yeah it's like it made
this drive
something that we can
share with you
what if ever like we were going
somewhere and we could
podcast yeah like wait like what if
we're yeah yeah like
we could do a podcast of us playing 20
questions like we do and keep in all of
the arguments that we get in from
playing 20 questions here's here's my
next idea for a card okay can not play
20 questions with each other because we
get in fights we literally get in fights
every time julian doesn't always
necessarily know all the answers to
questions but people you'll pick people
you know nothing about yeah then you'll
give me misleading answers okay okay
fair enough but also i will pick someone
i know everything about i will answer
all the questions perfectly and you'll
still find something wrong with the way
i answered something
oh my god i can't we can't even it's
like the self-fulfilling prophecy we
will fight every time we play that game
because we know we're gonna fight
everything my next idea for carcass is
we'll just order an uber sit in the back
seat where i love mike's and whisper
and if he asks us what we're doing we'll
just shake our heads
for like an hour
yeah
we'll have uber we'll have uber sponsor
that podcast so we're brought to you by
uber this uber ride is the sponsor his
name's sal
thank you
we appreciate it yeah that's what we'll
do
if you're on the app at all make sure
you just you keep pressing send me a
card until you get sell
like that's the call to action like just
spam uber until sal picks you up
oh
keep asking for rides he's a good guy
he's a good guy
don't blink at me i didn't even blink
this is a fun podcast it was fun
i like being out in the world but yeah
it was fun yeah
hopefully uh it didn't give any of you
guys anxiety secondhand from watching me
drive i know that can happen sometimes
firsthand anxiety
this is scarring me right now from you
having the experience
and anxiety from people staring at you
i have fourth hand anxiety from when the
camera fell and i went to the other lane
i have fifth hand anxiety from all the
ambulances i have six handed anxiety
from all the hands of anxiety that we
have
and they exist
on my bottom half
what am i supposed to do with them
i don't know
they're nervous uh thank you guys for
hanging out with us for another podcast
yeah i hope you enjoyed carcass 2k16 the
camera cut or like chopped it yeah we
will i will do my best putting this
together um to make sure it's nice
ain't good enough are we going to run
out of gas oh my god i have more anxiety
18 miles says i have left oh my god
um
we'll see you guys next week make sure
you check out the sponsors in the
description below
me and these
makes podcasts free for you guys and
they have dope stuff
i
you guys have a great week
don't podcast in the car unless you want
to and then podcast in the car we'll see
you guys
we'll see you guys next monday for
another podcast and we'll see you
tonight for the stream
we appreciate you
we love you very much
you